well PhD student has to have the
technical background to in the area of
study which which is a given if they're
up what they're applying but what I like
to see is PhD students who are
enthusiastic about the topic that that
they're gonna be studying and are ready
to get going on it and genuinely want to
push the frontiers of knowledge and they
want to go out and share it you're
looking for some sort of spark of an
independent thought
sometimes that's quite difficult to tell
because it costs bright students to come
out of degrees they're often all of us
were kind of we're getting problems we
know there are solutions to and we get
good at solving or a bit like doing
crosswords but when you're doing
research is different because the first
thing you have to do is work out what
the puzzle is you know it's identifying
the questions in research is is more
important than identifying the answer
because there are lots of questions that
are not interesting and there are lots
of questions that are interesting but
just don't have are very easy answers
and having that instinct for sort of
almost like an entrepreneurialship
actually with ideas is this is a
question that's worth answering that
someone else cares about other than me
and which can be answered that's the
real thing so I I look for a kind of
spark
well usually you're looking for a strong
academic record undergraduate
increasingly people with master's level
qualifications so here exto we have a
four year program in mathematics and
those students tend to be the ones in
other good students who come along
people who can communicate this is very
useful because eventually you will have
to become a scientist to write a thesis
you have to go to people talk about your
work so so really the ones who have the
good academic record and and are good at
communicating with me
you are most likely to succeed I have
got my fingers burnt by going for people
that I speak well and actually that
turns out not to be a very good way to
assess PhD students communicating there
does it becomes part of their scientific
career but when you're doing a PhD you
really looking for someone who's gonna
really focus on what they're doing
connect to some extent but actually have
a real drive to understand their problem
you know so I I these days I look for
people that are quite focused but also
have a going to drive to understand
things they kind of get research it
excites them neither one does mean some
people do research because they think
this is sort of what we do I'm a club I
did a good degree we come to their PhD
and they just think they never really
get it and there was no light goes onto
no point do they either think this is
really frustrating which is okay it
should be frustrating or this is really
exciting and interesting bit boring this
and they're not hired for a research
that bright people don't cut for respect
but the people that are cut out for you
can see it and it emerges generally in
the first year you start see a spark and
their eye when they're on to something
on anything okay they they've got what
it takes to be a researcher now that
layer between ten kilometers and fifty
comms annouced tubes is what we call a
stratosphere and it accounts for almost
the entirety of the remaining mass of
the atmosphere see ya let's see if I can
remember this or if you want more videos
with John and I just talking about stuff
then please condo make sure you go and
look at that singing playlist above
choral music about Christmas comment
below which one pieces your favorite you
know just have a listen to a few and
shuffles